[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN TALARICO: Welcome to
"Super-charge Your GKE
Development Workflows
with IDE Extensions."
My name is Ian.
ETAN SHAUL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Etan.
IAN TALARICO: Before
we get started,
we'll do a little
quick about us.
ETAN SHAUL: Yeah,
so my name is Etan.
I've been at Google for
about three years now.
I work on the Google
Cloud Platform.
Currently, I'm
the Technical Lead
for Cloud Code for IntelliJ.
And in my spare time, I
enjoy traveling and doing
some snowboarding.
IAN TALARICO: And my name's Ian.
I also work on Google
Cloud Platform.
I've been there for
about six years,
and I'm based out of Seattle.
I am the Technical Lead for
Cloud Code for Visual Studio
Code, which is a partner
effort to what Etan is working
on I also like to travel, but
instead, I pictured my dog here
who I think is adorable.
So Cloud Code, Etan and
I have both said it.
What is it?
So Cloud Code is a set
of integrated tooling
that aims to make
working with Kubernetes
and cloud native
applications easier.
We want to make that
development process simpler.
We know it's hard.
We've seen people work with it.
They struggle.
There's a lot of moving pieces.
You have your YAML.
You have worrying
about the statefulness
of your application,
and then your code.
So what we've done
is we've tried
to break it up into a
couple different portions.
We kind of have something
for the developers,
and we have people
on the DevOps side.
And we understand
there's overlap,
and of course, you'll
probably end up
using both parts
of these tooling,
but what we have
for the developers--
so who in the audience here,
your primary job is writing
code, you're a developer?
Show of hands.
All right, a lot of
developers here, good.
So we've got some
good stuff for you.
So what we try and
do is we understand
that working with
Kubernetes means
you have to work with a
cluster, but a lot of the times
you just want to
be writing code.
So to make it easier, we try
and make it as close as possible
to your local
development experience.
So when you're working with
your code, you're writing code,
and in the background, we
handle building your image,
building your application,
pushing it off
to your GKE cluster or
your Kubernetes cluster,
whatever you're working
with, and it's there
when you're ready to check
it out and work with it.
On top of that, the debugging,
we've tried to simplify that.
We make it easy.
If you have a pod selector,
you can very simply just
debug a remote cluster,
no problem at all.
And then on the DevOps
side, who is a little more
on the DevOps side?
All right, we've got a
lot of DevOps in here too.
You're going to see some
pretty cool features.
So we give you some
support in the IDE
to help you understand the
state of your application,
see what things are live and
what's not, if there's issues,
view events that have happened
recently, and on top of that,
easily diagnose issues.
You can use the
debugging, but also
look into the logs
and other things.
We also give some
great tooling to help
make the YAML a little
easier to consume,
and able to go back and
forth from what's local
on your machine, that
YAML you have there,
against the server YAML.
So Etan now is going to
give us a little bit deeper
dive into some of the
features we have to offer.
ETAN SHAUL: All right.
Thanks, Ian.
So before we look a little bit
closer at some of the features
that Cloud Code
has to offer, just
to get an idea of what people
here are using in the room,
if I could get a show of
hands, how many people
here use VSCode on
a regular basis?
Wow, a lot of you.
And what about JetBrains or
one of the other IntelliJ-based
IDEs?
OK, cool.
And then what about something
else, some other editor?
Makes sense.
All right, so let's
take a closer look
at some of the features
of Cloud Code for IDEs.
So, first of all, the
inner development loop.
What is that?
So imagine that you're
tasked with building
an application or a
microservice that needs
to run on a Kubernetes cluster.
One of the first
things you might
want to do after figuring out
basic tasks like firing up
your favorite editor, setting
a version control, and so on,
is actually running
your application,
so opening up a web browser,
hitting the endpoint assuming
it's a web app, and then
verifying and making sure
that everything
works as intended,
and then iterating on your
code, so in other words,
setting up that inner
development loop.
Now, since your
application is going
to be deployed to a
Kubernetes cluster,
it's probably pretty important
that your development
environment mirror production
as closely as possible.
This means running
on an actual cluster.
Now, this could be a local
cluster like Minikube
or a cluster on
Docker for desktop,
or if you have the
resources available to you,
it could be on a remote
cluster on one of the cloud
providers like GKE on GCP.
Right.
So if you've ever tried to
set up this process manually,
you know it's not
such an easy task.
You have to figure out how to
build your container image,
tag it, push it to a
container repository,
update your manifests, deploy
everything, and then repeat
this every time you change
your code, all of this
while you're trying to
focus on writing your code
and getting your business
logic working properly.
So we think the
IDE is a good place
to try and tackle some
of these problems,
because we all know that
context switching can really
kill productivity.
So our tooling will help here.
We'll create new targets
for you in the IDE
in the form of new commands
in the command palette
if you're a VSCode user and new
run configurations if you're
an IntelliJ user that will help
you, with a single click, setup
this development workflow.
So the tooling will take
care of building the image,
pushing it out to a repository,
deploying your application.
And the tooling will
sit there and watch
for changes in your
source code, and then
surface it live on a cluster
every time something changes
so you can quickly
verify your code.
And again, let me stress, this
can be any Kubernetes cluster,
so it can be a local
development cluster
or it can work on any
of the cloud providers.
And when you're done
with development,
the tooling will take
care of cleaning up
the deployed artifacts for you.
So much like the feel of a
local development server,
but with the power
and the fidelity
of running on a real
Kubernetes cluster.
All right, next, debugging.
So at some point,
inevitably, you're
going to run into issues
with your application.
So at this point, it's
probably really important
that you be able to
set up a debugger,
so this means setting
breakpoints, stepping
through your code, viewing the
call stack, local variables,
being able to run
expressions, and so on.
But remember, our
application now
is running inside of a container
and on a cluster somewhere,
so setting this up manually
is not really that trivial.
You have to set up the proper
language-specific debug
configuration,
inject that properly,
setting up the
environment variables,
doing the port forwarding, and
attaching a remote debugger.
Our tooling will help here.
Again, with a
single click, you'll
be able to set up a
debugger and attach it
to your service or even
your set of microservices
and debug your
application as easily
as if it were running locally.
Cool.
So now you can set up
your development workflow
and you can debug your code.
One thing, at this point, that
might be interesting to do
is gain some insight into
the state of your cluster.
So this means digging
down into the resources,
checking to see if
your pods are healthy,
maybe streaming logs
from a container,
or even viewing remote YAML
to make sure things are there
as you expect them.
And our tooling,
again, will help here
in the form of an
IDE resource browser.
So at some point,
you're going to want
to expand your application,
add more features,
add more functionality.
And this probably means more
configuration, more YAML.
Our tools will help
you work with this
by providing templates
and editing support,
so things like auto-completion
and quick documentation, all
the things you'd expect
from an editing experience
inside of an IDE.
We also have integrations with
popular tools and libraries.
A couple of examples--
first, Skaffold.
Skaffold powers much of
the inner loop experience
and the deployment
that I talked about.
And in the demo, you'll
see us dig in a little bit
into the configuration there.
JIB-- you'll see
this in the demo too.
JIB stands for
Java Image Builder.
So for you Java
developers out there,
JIB is a tool that helps you
easily containerize your Java
applications.
You don't need to
have Docker installed.
You don't even need to
write a Docker file.
All you need to do
is drop in a snippet
into your pom.xml or
your build.gradle,
depending on what you're using.
Lastly, we have some key
integrations with Google Cloud
Platform products, and I'll
give a couple examples.
So the first one
is an API browser.
In the demo, you'll
see that we're
going to be using the
Google Cloud Vision
API to extract some
features from a book image.
With the API browser,
inside the IDE,
you'll be able to discover
available APIs like the Google
Cloud Vision API, add
the associated client
library to your
build automatically,
and even do things like enable
the API on your cloud project
and setup authentication like
creating service accounts,
attaching roles to it so you
don't have to switch over
to the web console.
Great, so I'm going
to hand it off to Ian
now to kick off the demo.
IAN TALARICO: All right.
So hopefully, at
this point, you guys
aren't sick of us talking yet.
We're going to talk for just
one more slide real quick
to give you--
let's go the right
direction there--
to give you a quick
overview of what
we're going to demo
in our application
so you have an idea
about what we're doing
when we're talking about it.
So you see this kind of square
with rounded edges there?
This is just a cluster.
And in this case,
we're using GKE,
but you could,
realistically, use anything.
It just needs to be
a Kubernetes cluster.
Etan's going to use
Docker for desktop.
You could use Minikube.
You could use a
cluster on Azure, AWS.
It really doesn't matter.
It just needs to be a cluster.
And in that cluster, we have
two kind of sets of service.
You see the bookshelf which is
just a bookshelf application--
you can add a book to it, and
we'll talk a little bit about
that later on--
as well as an image
recognition service.
And what that does is
it does some smarts
to make our bookshelf
application a little bit
cooler.
The bookshelf app is talking
to some data services on GCP
to help us store some data, and
the image recognition service
is also talking to some APIs
around Vision and some books
which-- pretty cool API to get
some information about books.
So that's just a quick
high-level overview
of what's happening
there, and now we're
going to go ahead and
jump over to the demo.
Cool, all right.
So we've got VSCode here.
So it looked like most of you
in the audience here were VSCode
users, but quickly, I'll explain
for those of you who aren't.
Command shift P
or control shift P
is going to open up
the command palette.
So we're going to be using
that throughout the talk,
and that gives you
a list of commands
you can access and run.
And for the instance of this
talk, we have Cloud Code.
And these are all
the contributions
that we've made, that you
can use in the browser.
So for instance, if you're a new
user, you don't have a cluster,
you don't have code set up,
we can help you get started.
And we can start out by saying,
I want to create a cluster,
and I'm just going to
type create cluster.
And we can see here, I
can easily end the IDE.
I can create a GKE cluster
or even AWS or Azure.
So if I want to
create a cluster,
all I do is pop into here.
I'm going to fill out some basic
information and then hit save.
I'm not going to
do this right now.
It'll take a few minutes to go.
We already have a cluster set up
for us, but it's pretty simple.
So once we have that cluster
created, I don't have anything.
Again, I can use
the command palette,
and I can say cloud
code new application.
And what we have here
is a set of examples
of some simple applications.
We have hello world
and guestbook.
The hello world is a very
simple one-service microservice
application, and
then the guestbook
is a couple of microservices
that's just a guestbook.
You can go and you can write
your name and a message,
and it will save it there.
And we have support for
Python, Go, Node.js, Java,
.NET Core just to make sure that
you can start in the language
you're comfortable with.
So if we go here, we'll start
with the guestbook node.js just
to give you an idea of
what's in this application
and how you can get set up.
So we have the .idea folder
for the IntelliJ users,
if you want to start there,
and we have the .vscode folder
for the VSCode users.
And we have everything
set up for you.
We have the launch.json
so you can see here,
here's how we're
doing our debugging.
Here's our debug configurations.
And then we have some
Kubernetes manifests,
some source, its pretty
simple application,
and then lastly, the last
cool thing here we have is
that Skaffold file.
So Etan mentioned
Skaffold earlier,
and this is the engine
that's kind of powering
a lot of the deployments.
And we'll dive a little
bit more into this
file a little bit later on.
So let's go back
to my application,
and so this is that
bookshelf application
that I mentioned before.
So it's similar
to the guestbook.
It has a similar structure.
They were actually based
off the original sample.
So we have it here.
Let's just go ahead
and deploy it.
So I'm going to go back
to the command palette,
and I'm just going to say
cloud code and deploy.
And we see here, we have two
different types of deployments.
We have deploy and
continuous deploy,
and continuous deploy is
what Etan was talking about.
This is the deployment,
when I hit deploy--
I'm going to deploy
to my dev cluster--
it's going to do a
deployment, and then it's
going to sit and wait.
It's going to wait for me to
do changes to my application,
so I don't have
to worry about it.
You see it building the image.
It's pushing it.
And already, it's rolled out
and I can go view that endpoint.
So I'm going to go view
it, and here's my bookshelf
application.
So I'm going to go ahead and
add a book just to give you
an idea of what happens here.
Let's go ahead and say the
title of our book, "Kubernetes--
Up and Running."
Who's read that before?
OK, you guys should
read that book.
It's a really good book.
It's written by Kelsey,
Brendan, and Joe.
I don't really remember
when it was published.
The description, if I remember,
it was a super cool book.
And then we can choose the
image, the cover image.
So here's the cover
image, "Kubernetes--
Up and Running."
And I'm going to hit OK, and
then I'm going to save it.
And then like that,
we've got our book.
And we can go back, and
we have our bookshelf.
That's pretty cool.
I've got my description.
When I click into it, I have
a little bit more stuff.
So me, being the
book lover I am, I'm
going to go back to VSCode
and I'm going to say,
every time that I
upload a book, I
want the description to say
Ian really likes this book,
if I could spell.
There we go.
Typing in front of
people, so hard.
Right?
And as soon as I hit
save, we can see here
that we've already
kicked off another build.
So I'm not doing anything.
I'm saving my code, I'm
working, and the deployments
are happening.
Now, what I want you to remember
is that this is not local.
This is happening
against a GKE cluster.
So it doesn't feel like I'm
having to do anything special
and I'm just working with
that deployment remotely.
So while this is
building, I'm going
to go ahead and go back
to that Skaffold file
like I promised you.
So here's the Skaffold file.
And so what we have is we have
a default deployment at the top,
and then we have profiles.
And we can think about
profiles, they're
kind of like environments.
So we have a dev environment
and a QA environment.
And you can see here
our build artifact.
And we do nothing
special, we're just
going to use Docker
to do these builds.
And then we have a deploy
step and we're using kubectl.
We can actually do other
things like kustomize and helm
in here.
And then we have the manifest
we want to use to build it.
When we jump down to QA, again,
we have that same build here,
but now we're using
googleCloudBuild.
So we're using googleCloudBuild.
We're going to
build our images off
in the server to give us a
little bit more reliable,
consistent deployment when
we're working with our QA.
And again, you see down here, we
have another deploy definition.
And at the top,
we're using dev here
and QA down here at the bottom.
So now it looks like my
application has been deployed,
so we'll go back over here.
And I'm going to go
back to the books,
and I'm going to try
and add another book.
We'll do "Kubernetes--
Up and Running" again.
I still don't remember
when it was published.
Hopefully we can
figure that out later
with something Etan will do.
And then I'm going to
go and use that again.
Great.
So now, every
time, I also added,
Ian really likes this book.
And of course, I
didn't add a space.
But you can see
here how easy it was
for me to change my
application, change my code,
and just deploy right away.
So what Etan did that we
talked about in the beginning
was the image recognition
service that he wrote.
So being the semi-lazy
engineers we were,
we didn't have to type
all this stuff in.
I can't remember when a book's
been created, published.
I probably can't spell
the author's last names.
So I'm going to go
with this, and we
call this the auto
awesome feature
because we think
it's pretty cool.
And all I have to do now is
I have to go to that book
and I open it up, and it will
pull all the information it
needs from Cloud Vision.
And then it can grab additional
information from a book's API.
So I'm going to hit save.
And this is going to take a
little bit longer than normal
because it's calling some
extra APIs in the back end,
it's taking some time
to process the image.
And now, of course, now that
I'm sitting here talking to you,
I realize this is probably
taking a little bit longer
than it should.
So I'm going to go ahead
and stop this request,
go back to my bookshelf.
OK, we still have the
two books we had before,
but something's not right.
So now's a good time to
demonstrate our debugging
capability.
So we're going to go
over to our debugger,
and all we're going to do
is we're going to hit debug.
And this was that
launch.json file
I showed you guys originally.
And just like that
in our terminal.
There we go.
And the debugger is attached.
One click, a matter of seconds.
We handle all the port
forwarding for you,
making sure we're selecting
the right pods and everything.
So let's go ahead
and go to our--
this is, right here,
the method that
does happen when we do our
post request to add a book.
And I'm just going
to start adding
a couple of breakpoints
in here, and see
if we catch anything funny.
There's the auto awesome
feature you can see in the code.
And just to be safe, let's
catch on all caught exceptions.
All right, so I'm
going to go back here.
I'm going to try that again.
Auto awesome, add my book,
and I'm going to hit save.
And just like that, we
hit a breakpoint right
in our application.
So again, one more
time, this is all
happening on a remote
cluster and it doesn't really
feel like I'm doing
anything different.
So we'll start
stepping through this
and see if anything's happening.
OK, it was created
by anonymous user.
That's fine.
We weren't signed in.
We have a public image URL.
That's great.
I probably should remove
that before I deploy to QA.
I don't think our QA
engineers will like that.
And let's see here, we're
inside the auto awesome feature.
And just like that,
unable to open a file.
And we can see up
here, because I
turned catching all
uncaught exceptions on,
we have a failure.
Request to image
rec 8080 failed.
So that's because I'm working
in my local development cluster,
and it's just my cluster.
No one one else
has access to it,
and Etan hasn't deployed
the service he wrote to it.
So we kind of know
what the issue is.
Our auto awesome
feature isn't working
because it's just not there.
So I'm going to go ahead and
I'm going to stop this debugger,
and I'm going to do a quick
deploy, a single deploy
to our QA cluster.
And while that's
kicking off, I'm
going to go ahead and
let Etan take over.
And hopefully he can create
the right image recognition
service, and we can link the
two up and have a great product.
Thanks, Etan.
To you.
ETAN SHAUL: Cool, great.
Can we switch over
to demo two please?
OK, there we go.
So I'm going to switch
over to IntelliJ right now.
I have IntelliJ IDEA
open, and I happen
to be using Java to
build the service.
Lets go into configure
plugins really quick.
So you can see here, we have
the cloud code plugin installed.
This is now publicly
available in the marketplace.
And just to point
out, this works
with all of the JetBrains IDEs.
So if you're a Python
user, for example,
this will work with
PyCharm, GoLand.
So I started working on this
service before the demo,
and I have it deployed to Cloud
Source Repositories, which
is Google's hosted Git repos.
So I'm going to
clone it from there.
I'm going to clone
the repo from there.
Let's clone it into
a local folder.
Let's call it image rec.
I'm going to clone it.
OK, so it's cloning it right
now from Cloud Source repos,
and it's prompting me
to open the project.
There we go.
So the project is now
open and immediately, you
can see a couple prompts.
So this is a Maven project
that it detected upon,
so I'm going to add it just
so that everything syncs.
And you can see
another prompt here.
It detected that this is a
Kubernetes ready project,
and it's prompting me to create
a couple of run configurations.
So I'm going to accept that.
And then immediately, here,
you see a couple new targets
available, and these are
analogous to the commands
in the command palette that Ian
showed you earlier in VSCode.
We have deploy and develop.
Deploy does a single deployment
to Kubernetes, and that's it.
Develop runs through
the whole pipeline,
deploys your application,
but then stays open
and watches for
changes in your source,
and then redeploys every
time things change.
We'll see that in a second.
So let's just quickly look at
the structure of this project.
So like I said, this
is a Maven project.
It happens to be
a spring boot app.
We have the Skaffold YAML here.
Ian got into it a little bit.
We have the build
strategy defined here
pointing to our artifacts, and
we have the deploy strategy
here as well using kube control
and pointing to our Kubernetes
manifests.
So we have a couple
manifests here,
one used for dev and one
used for the QA environment.
The dev adds some secrets for
mounting the service account
to access the remote API.
So let's look at our source.
So we have a simple
controller here.
Let's first set up the JDK
so everything resolves.
There we go.
So have a couple endpoints here.
So we have an image endpoint--
this is the endpoint that
the bookshelf application
is going to hit--
and then a couple
debug endpoints
that I'm using just
to show you what's
going on in the application.
We'll see that in a second.
And we have a service here
called the default feature
extraction service, and
this is the service that's
responsible for calling
out to the Cloud Vision API
as well as the book's API to do
some extraction from the book
image.
And you can see there's a lot
of a class path issues here.
These all look like classes that
are part of the Cloud Vision
API.
That's OK.
That means that I can show
you some other features now
that we have.
So I'm going to quickly go to
tools and select Cloud Code.
We have a couple actions
here available to us.
Right now, I'm
interested in this one,
so I'm going to click
add cloud libraries
and manage cloud APIs.
So we get this API explorer
that I talked about earlier,
and in particular,
right now, we're
interested in the Cloud
Vision API like I mentioned.
So I'm going to select that.
We get some information
about the API,
links to documentation
and so on.
Let me select the cloud project.
So, in this case, we're working
with the bookshelf application,
bookshelf next 2019.
You can see here that
it's going to add it
to the main module,
the image rec module,
and it's going to
use the latest BOM.
And what that
means, it just means
that it's going to pull in the
latest version of the client
library, so the Cloud
Vision client library.
And you can see some
other things here.
So, by default, I have selected
to enable the API in the Google
Cloud Platform.
So I'm going to
keep that selected.
Otherwise, I would have had
to go into the Cloud console
and manually enabled it.
So I'm going to continue.
So at this point, we get some
authentication tasks here.
So creating a service account
and downloading the key,
I already did this
before the demo
so we can skip that step now.
I'm going to accept that.
So it's enabling the API on
the Cloud platform right now.
We get a prompt here confirming
that the library was added
to the pom, and it's
prompting me to import
the changes to sync with Maven.
So I'm going to import
that and hopefully,
everything resolves now.
There we go.
So just to take a
look at what it did--
so I just diff the pom.
You can see that it added the
right client library to my
build, so now the Google Cloud
Vision API has been important.
So at this point, I think we're
ready to try and run the app
and see if everything
works properly.
So I'm going to use this
develop on Kubernetes,
run configuration here.
Let's just edit
it to quickly look
at some of the settings
that are available.
So it automatically detected
my Skaffold configuration,
and it's auto-populated
with a couple profiles.
So there's always
the default profile,
and I also had this Google Cloud
build profile available to me.
Let's just stick with the
default profile for now.
And before I run it,
just to point out,
I'm pointing right now to Docker
for desktop just because I
think that's an
efficient way to work,
so I have that
selected right now.
So let's run it in debug mode.
This way, I can preview some
of the debugging features
that we're going to be putting
out in a upcoming release.
So it's running through the
whole pipeline right now.
What it's going to
be doing is it's
going to build my application.
It's going to containerize it.
It's going to push it out
to a container repository,
and then it's going to
deploy everything and apply
the manifest using kube control.
So a couple of interesting
things here to see.
So it did some port
forwarding for me.
So you can see, it port
forwarded the application port,
port 8080, which is the default
port that spring boot uses.
And also, interestingly, it
did some other things here.
It port forwarded
port 5005, which
happens to be the default debug
port used by JDWP, the Java
Debug Wire Protocol.
And it also injected this
language-specific argument
for me, set it up as
an environment variable
in the Java tools options.
And nowhere in my code
or my configuration
did I have to set
this up manually.
The plugin took care of
injecting these arguments
for me so that debugging
will be set up.
So then the spring boot
application is loading,
and it looks like it's
complete at this point.
So we can jump over
to the web browser,
and let's hit that
debug endpoint.
OK, so we just have a simple
form to just debug and make
sure things are
working properly.
So I'm going to select this
book, "Effective Java."
It's probably familiar to you
Java developers out there.
So I'm going to select that
and I'm going to upload it.
So what happened here?
I got back some JSON
with the features
from the book, so the
title, description,
author, and published
date, but it
doesn't look like it actually
got anything interesting out
of the book.
This just seems like
placeholder text.
So that's good.
We can now debug the application
and figure out what's going on.
So let's go into our
image upload controller,
insert a breakpoint
right before it's
about to call the feature
extraction service,
and see if we can
figure out why it's not
getting any real data here.
So the breakpoint's set.
I'm going to select
the same book again
and I'm going to upload it.
And you can see it immediately
hit the breakpoint.
And again, this application is
running in Docker for desktop.
So I'm going to shift F7 and
step into the extract text
method to see.
OK, so I can immediately see
what the problem is here.
So it's using this test
feature extraction service
which is just a stub that I
made for testing purposes,
basically hard
coding the values.
So that's not what we want.
I forgot to inject the right
version of the service.
So let's step out of that.
Let's upload this one
more time so that we
hit the first breakpoint.
And at this point, let's
cheat a little bit.
So I'm going to right click
on the feature extraction
service, the local variable,
and click set value.
And let's set it to the new
default feature extraction
service right there.
So I'm going to
apply that, and it's
going to hot-swap
the changes directly
into the running application.
So at this point, I
can step out of it,
and hopefully, now, it's
calling the Cloud Vision API
and it will give me
some real information.
So there we go.
So this looks a
little bit better now.
We got some information
back from the book.
We got the title, the
author, and the publish date.
And just for debugging
purposes, I'm
showing an annotated image
with the bounding boxes
for the features that it found.
What's happening
is it's basically
just using a simple heuristic
to find the title of a book
and then calling out
to the book's API
to get the remaining
information.
But it looks like we still
have a little bit of a problem.
The description here is
null, so let's go back
and see if we can debug that.
So I'm going to go into my
default feature extraction
service, and go down to where
it's pulling that description,
so right here.
So it looks like it's
pulling the description
from this volume info object.
So let's upload one more time.
So this is the
original breakpoint.
Let's step out of that.
There we go.
So now, let's open the
expression evaluator really
quick, and let's look and see
what's inside of volume info.
So volume info, it's
calling get subtitle.
And indeed, you can see
it's returning null.
So let's look and see what
else is available here.
So immediately, I see
get description here
looks like the one we should
have been using all along,
and we have the real
information here.
So let's fix that.
So I'm just going to
fix it really quick.
And at this point, I
could wait for everything
to rebuild and
redeploy, but that's
longer than I want to
wait so I'm just going
to do control shift F7 now.
Or sorry, control shift F9.
And what that's
going to do, it's
going to recompile
just this class,
and the IDE is going to detect
that the classes changed
and prompt me to reload them.
So I'm going to say yes,
and so now these changes
were live reloaded into
the running application.
So now, at this point, I should
be able to do one last test
and verify that
everything is working.
And of course, we still hit the
breakpoint, and there we go.
So now we have all the
information that we need,
and we should be ready to
push this application up
to the QA environment to test
the end to end integration.
So let's go back.
So I'm done with developing
right now, so let's kill this.
And now, we want to push this
up to the QA environment.
So I'm going to switch from
Docker for desktop and point
to my QA cluster.
And if you recall, I mentioned
that we have these two
sets of Kubernetes manifests.
And currently, the QA manifests
are not properly wired in,
so we can do that really quick.
I'm going to open up
the Skaffold YAML.
And the way we're going
to do this is we're
just going to add a
new profile to point
to the right manifests.
So I'm going to use
the editing support.
So let's add a new profile
and let's call it QA.
And we're going to override
the deployment configuration.
And we're still going to
use kube control here,
but you can see that you
have some other options
here, some other
deployment strategies.
If you're using helm or
kustomize, you can use that.
So I'm going to select kube
control, and then manifests,
and then point to
my web QA manifest.
So that looks good.
And now I'm going to switch
over to the deploy to Kubernetes
run configuration.
Let's edit it.
So it's still pointing
to the default profile,
but it automatically detected
that I created a new profile.
So I'm going to select it, and
let's choose to tail the logs
after deployment in case
something goes wrong.
So I'm going to apply
that and I'm just going
to run the single deployment.
So it's kicking off
the pipeline right now,
building everything, pushing it
out into a container registry,
and deploy my application.
And while that's running,
just to point out,
you may have noticed that
there's no Docker file
here anywhere in this project.
That's because I'm
using the tool called
JIB which I explained a
little bit about earlier.
You can see here, I'm using it
in the form of the JIB Maven
plugin.
It's as simple as this.
Gives you a lot of configuration
options, but getting started
is just as easy as dropping
in this Maven plugin.
And that'll containerize
your application
efficiently without
needing Docker
and without even needing
to write a Docker file.
So let's check on the
status of our deployment.
It looks like it's already
complete, so that's good.
Now let's jump over
to the QA environment.
So here we are again.
I'm going to choose
to add a book,
and I'm going to use
this auto awesome feature
that Ian talked about.
Now let's choose the same
book as before and save it.
And so hopefully, now
the bookshelf application
is going to be calling out to
my image recognition service.
But, of course, we got an error
because this is a live demo.
Let's try one more time.
IAN TALARICO: You forgot
to change test to default.
ETAN SHAUL: Oh, right.
Thank you.
So remember that I had
that injection issue
where I was injecting
the test stub version?
I forgot to swap that out
because we live reloaded it.
IAN TALARICO: That's
how you know it's live.
ETAN SHAUL: So thank you,
Ian, for catching that.
So let's open up the controller
really quick, and here we go.
Let's swap it out to
the default service.
Perfect.
So, at this point, we should
still be using the QA profile,
and let's redeploy again.
So this should be pretty quick.
So it's going to build my image.
Looks like the build
was successful,
and the deployment was complete.
So now the spring
boot app is starting,
and it should be done
in any second now.
There we go.
All right, let's test
that out one more time.
Let's add a book.
Select "Effective Java"
again, and save it.
There we go.
This looks like it's
taking a little longer now,
so it's hopefully calling out to
the right API, and there we go.
We've extracted all the
features from the book image,
and we didn't have
to type anything.
So I think we're happy with
our application right now.
Everything looks good
in the QA environment,
so I'm going to
hand it back to Ian
to show you some more
cool features in VSCode.
IAN TALARICO: So
that's a good thing.
If you guys realize how
fast that second build was,
that was JIB, right?
So that was considerably
faster than the first time
because JIB was able to rebuild
the image for you faster
with the existing
pieces of a Docker file.
ETAN SHAUL: It granularly
layers the image
so that it only needs to
rebuild the image to change.
So it splits up your
Java application
into its dependencies,
resources, and your source
files, and only the
layer of the change
gets rebuilt. So obviously, that
leads to much faster container
builds.
IAN TALARICO: Can we go
back to demo one, please?
Cool, just like that.
All right, so Etan
and I have talked
through a lot of the
developer story for everyone,
and you've seen the developer
inner loop and debugging
and how simple we can
make that for you.
So we're going to touch
a little bit right now
on what be providing for
the DevOps side of things,
looking at your
Kubernetes cluster
and working with some YAML.
So we're going to
jump right into it.
So here, we have this
contribution here on the bottom
left, and we can see here we
have a couple of explorers.
So the bottom one, we have
a Google Kubernetes engine
explorer.
And this is a pretty
simple explorer.
It has my account.
You can see here the Google
Cloud project I'm using
as well as the clusters it has.
The explorer itself
is pretty simple.
It gives you some creation
time, some public endpoints,
the status of it.
But what the real
power here is is I
can right click and
set as active cluster.
And that bumps it up
to my cluster explorer,
and that's this
explorer up here,
and this is where we have
all the great features.
So right now, you
can see here, I
have the QA and my dev cluster.
And I'm going to
go ahead and I'm
going to expand my QA cluster.
And we're going to
see some information.
So I'm looking at the
default namespace right now.
Everything we did, we worked
in our default namespace.
And we can see we have our
deployments, pods, services,
even some custom
resource definitions,
and we can do this for
any namespace we have.
So if we go ahead and
look at our deployments,
you can see here, we have
our three deployments
deployed right here--
the bookshelf frontend
and worker as well as
that image recognition service.
So if we looked at my dev
cluster, for instance,
we wouldn't see that image
recognition service, which
is why my original test failed.
So we can go ahead and dive
into this a little bit deeper.
We can see here our
bookshelf frontend.
It gives us the
desired replica counts.
We can see here this little
green dot in the corner here.
I don't know if it shows
up on that screen as well,
but that's just kind of
the state of everything.
If it's green,
everything is good.
If there's some issues, it
will show a little yellow icon
there, and you can
dive and look into it.
And if there's something
that's going wrong,
you can definitely go ahead
and take a look at your events.
These are events from
the last 24 hours.
A lot of the times, if
something's going wrong,
you can go ahead
and look at that
and you can see some
of the issues just
like that from your IDE.
So I'm going to show you
one cool feature here.
So if I'm just playing around on
a test cluster or dev cluster--
I definitely don't suggest
doing this in production,
but I want a view
or edit my YAML.
Say I want a couple
more replicas.
I can just go right
here and I can pull up
the YAML from the server.
So this isn't my local YAML,
this is my server YAML.
And I see here I've
got two replicas.
I changed my mind.
I want three.
I'm going to save
it, and it asks me
if I want to apply
this configuration.
Again, not necessarily
best production practices,
but something you can do
if you're playing around.
You hit yes, and
just like that, we
can go back to our
cluster explorer,
and we've got three replicas.
So we can easily
change and modify
the state of our Kubernetes
clusters and applications
just from the IDE.
We can also look a little
bit more into our pods
to get some more diagnostics
about the application we're
working with.
You can see here, now we
have three frontend workers
because we just added one.
We also have our bookshelf
and the image recognition.
And from these, we can go
ahead and view and stream logs.
So if I want to view
logs, I can see the logs
that came from this pod.
And we can see here, we
had a couple requests.
This, there wasn't too
much traffic sent to it,
but we have our
post and our get,
and we can kind of see
what's happening there.
And if we want to dive a
little bit deeper, we can see,
here's our bookshelf
application,
and I could even get a
terminal into that pod,
into that container.
And you can see here, I'm
just going to do a quick ls.
And you can see here,
all these files here
is basically just what I
had in my explorer here.
And it enables me to be able
to dive a little bit deeper
into what's happening
and be right where
my application is running.
So let me go back to
our explorer here.
We can, of course, take a look
at our services, replica sets,
config maps, but we're
able to easily see
the state of our applications,
dive in, and change them
a little bit if we want.
So onto the set of features
we have for our YAML.
So we know that YAML's
a little bit difficult.
There's a lot of it.
When you start using
Kubernetes, maybe you
add it on Knative and
Istio and Kustomize,
and now you just
have piles of YAML.
And one of the things
you want to try and do
is help make that experience
easier for the user.
So right here, this
is our deployment.
It's a bookshelf
worker deployment.
You can see here, whenever I
want to see what's going on
and see what one thing is, I
can never keep these in my head.
So a spec-- what's
supposed to go on a spec?
There's quite a few things here.
So we, just on hover,
give you the ability
to see all the definitions
and potential fields.
And we can do this
for any of these,
and they'll give me an idea.
It should be a string.
It gives me a short description.
And on top of that, since
we know that information,
we can give you some completion.
So if I want to add
something, I can
get a list of all the
possibilities here,
as well as the
definitions for them.
So I know what I'm adding
and how I'm adding it.
And again, we can do
some even more smarts.
We know that our
replica is probably
going to be an integer.
If we hover over
this, I'm guessing
it'll tell me it's an integer.
And say we go ahead and
change this to cloud code.
Cloud code should not be
a valid set of replicas.
And we can see here,
we're getting an error.
It's incorrect type.
And so we can do some
type checking to help
you a little bit along the way.
And of course,
VSCode will give us
this nice red not happy path.
We can change that back.
And so one of my
absolute favorite things
that we can do
here in our YAML is
we have some insight
into what's happening
at the server or local level.
So you see here,
we have a config
map defined at the bottom.
And you see there's a
little hover above it that
says created four days ago.
So the first time this
was created on my cluster
was four days ago, and I can
dive into this a little bit.
So it's a config folder.
It's named config
folder, and I can
peek the definition of that.
And what happens is I
pop up a window here.
And you can see here, this
is the local definition
of this on my machine.
So I can see my
config map is here.
The name is config folder.
This is what we peeked
the definition of,
and then I have a project ID
which is just my Google Cloud
Project ID.
And if I want to see
what's going on again
with this at the server level,
I can go dive into that too.
And so here's my
server version of it.
This is what's on my
active cluster right now.
And I can look into this.
We can see Skaffold
adds some labels when
it does it's deployments.
We can see our last
applied configuration.
And if we go back
to our local file,
want to make some
changes, I can just
go ahead and click
onto that, and it
takes me right to my code
or to my YAML in the IDE.
So I'm more easily able
to work with my YAML
and navigate around it.
So these are all of the
features we have here for you
on the DevOps side of things.
If you want to see a little
bit more about this later,
we have another
talk coming up we'll
tell you about that
does a much deeper dive
into some of these features.
ETAN SHAUL: Let's just quickly
recap what we just saw.
So first, we worked on
the bookshelf application,
which was a two service app,
had a frontend and a backend.
And we saw how easy it was to
setup this local development
workflow, this inner
development loop.
With a single click, we were
able to set up this development
workflow where the
extension would
monitor for changes
in your source
and then surface them
live on the cluster.
And remember, the application
was running on GKE
in that case, on
Ian's dev cluster.
You also saw Ian,
with a single click,
attach a debugger
to the application
and step through it, and it
behaved as if the application
were running locally.
It was just as easy as that.
We then switched
over to IntelliJ
to build the image
recognition service, which
happened to be in Java.
We showed you much of
the same functionality
for the inner development loop.
Additionally, we showed you
debugging the application which
was running in
Docker for desktop,
and making changes
to a class file
and then live reloading
them, hot-swapping them
right into the
running application,
drastically reducing the
iteration cycle time.
Next we showed you some
ops types features,
so digging into your cluster,
looking at your pods,
seeing some events, streaming
logs from containers,
viewing remote YAML,
that kind of thing.
And lastly, we showed
you some functionality,
some editing support
for dealing with all
of your YAML configuration.
So what's next?
Well, first, we would
love for all of you
to try out these
tools and file issues
if you find them on GitHub
and make feature requests.
And we plan to continue building
out our Kubernetes support,
so more direct support for
tools like helm and kustomize
in the plugins, and more support
for Google Cloud Platform
products like integrations
with things like Cloud Build.
At this point, you
might be wondering
how to get your hands on these
tools, and Ian will tell you.
IAN TALARICO: Cool.
Thanks, Etan.
So the good stuff,
how do we get to it?
So we've got the Visual
Studio extension.
Cloud Code for
Visual Studio Code
is in the VSCode marketplace.
You can go ahead
and download it.
Cloud Code for IntelliJ is
in the JetBrains plugins
repository.
And we have our documentation,
cloud.google.com/code.
That QR code will take
you straight to the docs.
And from our docs,
you can get linked
to our issue tracking, feature
requests, things like that.
And I want to stress
what Etan said.
If you have feature
requests, ideas, thoughts,
please go ahead and
leave them for us.
It's a new product, we're
still developing it,
and we're building it for
you, for the developers,
for the DevOps.
So we want you to be
happy with the product.
We want you to have
the features in it
that you want to be
successful in your jobs.
So we greatly accept feedback.
So back to Etan.
ETAN SHAUL: Great.
Well, thank you, everyone.
That concludes our talk.
We have some related talks
that we can recommend if you're
interested in diving deeper.
Ian mentioned the first one,
Dead Easy Kubernetes Workflows
with VSCode, which will
dive a little bit deeper
into these workflows using
the VSCode extension.
It's tomorrow at 11:00 AM if
you're interested in that.
And we have another talk
that we can recommend
that will show you
a little bit more
with the Google Container
tools that we have available
and working with Cloud
Build, and that's also
tomorrow at 11:00 AM.
And we have our information up
here, so if any questions come
up later, feel free
to reach out to us
and we'll do our best
to get back to you.
And thanks everyone for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]